[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الولايات المتحده مقابل العريان
كان هذا عنوان الفيلم الوثائقي الذي حاز
على عده جوائز ووثق حكايه ضيفنا ومحاكمته
الشهيره في الولايات المتحده يتولى
الدكتور سامي العريان اداره مركز دراسات
الاسلام والشؤون الدوليه في تركيا وهو
كذلك استاذ للشؤون العامه في جامعه صباح
زعيم في اسطنبول نشر العديد من الكتب
والابحاث خلال اربعين عاما قضاها في
الولايات المتحده قبل ان يتم ترحيله منها
قام مؤرخ موسوعه المنشقين الامريكيين
بتوصيفه على انه واحد من ثلاثه مسلمين فقط
في الولايات المتحده من بين مئه واثنين
منشقا امريكيا وسجناء راي في القرن الماضي
تم تضمينهم في السلسله المكونه من مجلدين
جنبا الى جنب مع مالكوم اكس ومحمد علي
تناولته في الحلقه الماضيه سيرته الشخصيه
وحياته وانتقاله للولايات المتحده وتعرضنا
لمجريات قضيه الاشهر التي شهدها هناك
وانتهت بترحيله بعد احداث الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر وتناولوا في هذه الحلقه مجمل
افكارهم ومواقفه من القضيه الفلسطينيه
ورؤيته الناقده بشكل جذري لعمليه السلام
التي تؤدي برايه الى تاكل وتصفيه القضيه
الفلسطينيه سامي العريان ضيف الجزء الثاني
من المقابله فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته اهلا بكم في المقابله في الجزء
الثاني مع الدكتور سامي العريان استاذ
الشؤون العامه رئيس مركز الدراسات الاسلام
والشؤون العالميه
ضيفنا في الحلقه الثانيه مرحبا بك دكتور
تحدثنا في الحلقه الاولى عن مسيرتك
الطويله وعن انتهينا في الحلقه بمحاكمتك
المحاكمه الشهيره والتي ارخت من ضمن اهم
المحاكمات في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
المحاكمه من 2003 الى 2015 انتهت بخروجك
في محاكمتين
الاخرين بس ننهي المحاكمه الاولى انتهت
بتسويه 2006 زي ما يقولوا الاخوان
المصريين سيبوا نسيبوا فك الفك طبعا كانوا
من الصعب انهم يدنوك وبنفس الوقت انا لا
اريد ان ادخل في محاكمه اخرى غير مضمونه
النتائج وعايز مليون دولار اخرى وكانت
المساله انه قالوا لي وقتها انه اذا
تشابكت مع الحكومه الامريكيه في هذه تاخذ
سنين لان هؤلاء الناس لا يعني يقبلون
الهزيمه على الاطلاق اذا يوجد ما يدينك لم
يستطيعوا ادانتك بشكل رسمي بشكل قانوني
وقضائي عرضوا عليك تسويه ما هي التسويه
امشي تغادر الولايات المتحده
حقوقي وقتها تم الاتصال مع الحكومه
المصريه عمر سليمان كان مسؤول المخابرات
ووافق يعني
مصر لان اخر بلد جئت منهم
وهي الوثيقه اللي هي كانت منتهيه اصلا
كانت صادره ايضا
قلت يعني وافقنا طبعا الاعتبارات ايضا لها
علاقه بالعائله يعني العائله ايضا تضررت
منهكه جدا يعني انا قلت لك اكثر بالمليون
دولار على كل الاحوال فهذا كان القرار
ولكن هناك كان مدعي عام اخر صهيوني معروف
في ولايه اخرى ولم تعجبه هذه النتيجه
وافتعل لي محاكمه اخرى او قضيه اخرى هذه
القضيه كانت في متعلقه في قضيه هو اخترعها
وقال تاتي لتشهد فيها فاذا شاهدت سيقول
انك كذبت حتى لو قلت يعني
وفيها 25 سنه في لانها متعلقه بقضيه واذا
لم تشهد المحكمه ايضا
سنه وهذا كانت ما يريد عند طبعا هم
طالبوني بالتعاون قلت لا اتعاون معكم ونزع
قضيه التعاون من التسويه من الاتفاقيه
بيني وبينهم فاستمرت لم تكن شرطا في لم
تكن شرطا في التسويه انا رفضت قلت لهم اذا
حاكموني قالوا
فلما جاءت هذه المساله تقديرك ليش
يعني ان يجين مذنبا لا يستطيعوا ادانتك
ولا يريدون تبريئاتك ويريدون ان يعني
يختفي من المشهد يعني خلاص تعبتم خصوصا
انه كان لي يعني من 97 الى 2002 كان لي
نشاط سياسي وصلت فيه الى اعلى المستويات
قابلت جورج بوش ابن كلينتون وكل هؤلاء
الناس يعني
في اعلى مستويات
مش طبيعه هذا النشاط يعني كان كنت شخصا
لافتا اظن هذا حتى استفز الصهاينه دخلت
البيت الابيض جورج بوش الابن اثرت به
كثيرا
انه كان هناك كما قلت مع صعود الهيمنه
الامريكيه كان هناك اراده حقيقيه طبعا
ايضا يعني فيها نفوذ صهيوني كبير هو في
ضرب الوجود الاسلاميه في امريكا وبدا طبعا
من 93 وطالع يعني طبعا كان بعضه رد على ما
فعل القاعده في في بعض العملياتها على كل
الاحوال فكان هناك قانون جاء في سنه 96
اسمه قانون استخدام الادله السريه في
محاكمات الهجره فوقت احنا تشكلنا تحالف من
اربعين مؤسسه واختاروني رئيس له واصبح
هناك نشاط كبير جدا سياسي منه نشاط اعلامي
وسياسي وقانوني
والله يعني ليس بالتعريف اللوبي التقليدي
ولكن كان نشطا جدا هو الضغط واستطعنا ان
نؤثر في
يعني في قانون يعني عرضنا قانون هو عدم
استخدام الادله السريه تماما
وانا شخصيا تدخلت في هذه المساله بشكل
اسبوعي كنت اذهب وكان معنا اكثر من 130
عضو في الكونجرس وهذه مساله كانت بالنسبه
للصهاينه مقلقه جدا يكون عندك هذا العدد
ثم دخلنا على المجلس
مع الاحزاب السياسيه لحزب الديمقراطي
والجمهوري الحزب الجمهوري يعني كانوا
يعطونا بعض الامور يعني
الاكثر منها مجاملات ولكن عندما احتدم
الانتخابات عام 2000 فهم اهتموا انه
عايزين اي شيء اللي يغلبوا فيها الطرف
الاخر فجاءني دعوه انه يا اخي اذا انتم
تدعمونا في الرئاسه ايش تحتاجون منا قلت
له تحتاج انه هو
كان في المناظره الثانيه بين بوش وجور
جاءت قضيه التعامل مع السود والاقليات فهو
قال ايضا هناك تعامل خطا مع المسلمين في
استخدام الادله السريه وكان هذا جورج فقال
انا هيني اعطيتك انت طلبت مني
مليون امريكي فانتم لن تدعموني قلت له
طبعا فلجمعت ان كل القوى الاسلاميه
واتفقنا على دعم بوشي
ووقتها انا كنت عندي ولايه فلوريدا فوجهنا
كل التصويت في المسلمين وقتها فقدت هذه
الكلمه يعني ما كنت انا غافل عن موقف
فلسطين ولا العراق ولكن هذه المساله
والفكره كانت انه اذا استطاع المسلمون في
امريكا ان يحققوا انتصار في حقوقهم
المدنيه فهذا يعطيهم فرصه
الاسود في مواضيع فلسطين
في موضوع فلسطين كلهم في هذا المساله نحن
قانون استخدام هو كيف اللي صار اللي صار
انه هو فاز بثوره ده ب537 صوت واحنا
كمسلمين اعطيناه الاف الاصوات فهم ادركوا
ذلك ودعوني حتى قبل تنصيبه وشكروني
واعطوني حضور حفله تنصيبه يعني في ذلك
الوقت قل لنا طيب يلا الان اعطونا يعني
الغاء الادله السريه قالوا خلاص ندرسها
ونعملها وفعلا درسوها واتصلوا فيها في شهر
ثمانيه وقالوا لي درسناها وسنلغي سنريدك
ان تاتي بكل القيادات الاسلاميه في البيت
الابيض حتى نحتفل بهذا هذا اليوم كان هو
يوم 11/9 نفسه
فطبعا المسائل كلها تلخبطت تلخبطت لكن هذا
النشاط استفز الصهاينه بشكل كبير لمحاكمتك
تعتقد ان هناك دور الاستخبارات اسرائيليه
هذا الكلام موجود في
اولا هم جاؤوا ب 65 الف ورقه بالعبري
دفعوها في المحاكمه كان فيها حوالي 400
الف وثيقه خمسين الف ورقه عبريه وخمسه
وستين الف ورقه عبريه زائد ال 400 الف
ورقه وكانوا يسجلونني عشر ساعات 21 الف
ساعه التسجيل
استخدموا منها 400 مكالمه بحدود يمكن لا
تزيد عن 30 ساعه يعني هذا هذا من المتين
الف من عفوا من 471 الف مكالمه اختاروا
400 حتى يعني ما افلحت
الاستخبارات اعترفوا في اثناء المحاكمه
انهم نزلوا الى الى اسرائيل وتعاونوا معهم
21 مره
قالت في كيبل ما بين الصفاره الامريكيه في
تل ابيب وما بين انه هدول احنا بنتعاون
معهم في كل شيء ونحن ما كنا فاهمين شيء
وهم فهمونا كل هذه لماذا كان الاهتمام
الصهيوني بقضيه كبيره انا اعتقد انه لها
علاقه بنشاطي في امريكا لانه كنا نشاط
يعني وصل الى اعلى المستويات في داخل
الكونغرس وداخل الاروقه الخارجيه في داخل
اروقه الوايت الابيض وكانوا عود القضيه
الثانيه التي التي اثارها المدعي الذي طلب
وضعت بين خيارين الشهاده واتهامك بالكذب
25 سنه عدم الشهاده ازدراء للمحكمه 25 سنه
وش سويت وقلت انا مثلا لن اشهد فوضعوني في
السجن حتى يرضون على انفراد سنتين حتى اشد
ما شاهد بعد ذلك اذا ما شاهد يعمل لك قضيه
جنائيه هذه كل قضيه مدنيه يعني السجن هذا
غير محسوب هذا قضيه حتى يضغط عليك تشهد
عندما لا تشهد يعمل لك قضيه جنائيه حتى
يمشي في 25 سنه وقت الزراعه المحكمه 25
سنه وهذه مساله طبيعيه ولكن جاءت قاضيه
قالت يا جماعه هذا الرجل انتم اتفقتوا معه
واحنا بلدين كيف تتفقوا معه وبعدين تعملوا
له قضيه اخرى فشكت في الموضوع وقالت اريد
ان اتحدث مع اللي اتفق معهم فرفضت الحكومه
تجيب الناس اللي اتفقت معاهم في فلوريدا
فقالت بعنته في الامر شيء فاعطتني كفاله
قالت لي بس تجلس في اقامه جبريه في بيت
ابنتك بس تجلس بس ما تطلع يعني
تهمه ثم اقامه جبريه اقامه جبريه ورفضت
انها تحكم لما هم رفضوا يقولوا
لها ليش عملوا كذا ورفضوا يجيبوا الناس من
عشان تستجوبهم تركت القضيه لا هي عايزه
تحكم محكمه ولا عايزه تطلقني ولا تماما ست
سنوات هم لما بعد ست سنوات قالوا اذا هذه
لن تحكم شيء فهم اسقطوا القضيه الثانيه
وقالوا لي امشي 2014 نعم
اخراجك من الولايات المتحده كان غريب أنا
غريبا جدا كيف ليس انت لا تحمل جنسيه
الامريكيه لا احمل طبعا ان تنازلت عن كل
حقوقي كان المفروض انه
يعطوني اياه كل هذا تنازلت عليه
ما عندي حتى بطاقه شخصيه بطاقه تحقيق
شخصيه ما عندي شيء يعني نقول بدون اصبحت
بدون
ولكن طبعا الطياره ما تسمح الواحد بدون
شيء كيف تسافر من امريكا الى تركيا بالضبط
فقال الامريكان للاتراك اعطوه شيء قالوا
عندكم ما نعطيه شيء طب كيف يمشي قال انتم
توصلوا لنا اياه للطياره وفعلا اخذوني من
يعني من
منطقه امنيه لمنطقه امنيه بدون اي شيء لحد
لما وصلوني للطياره
لما نزلت في تركيا جماعه استقبلوني
واعطوني شيئا يعني
ومنحه الجنسيه التركيه نعم
وهذا كان موقفا يعني
نبيلا لم تجد بلد عربيه يفعل هذا الشيء
والله للاسف للاسف الشديد طلبت وقتها حتى
من تونس وهي كانت في وقت الثوره ومن بعد
البلاد الاخرى وكلهم قولوا ان شاء الله ان
شاء الله ولكن لم لم يتبرا احد يعني
ماذا خرجت من هذه التجربه الدكتور سامي
يعني حياتك كانت مزدهره في الولايات
المتحده نشاط وصلت الى البيت الابيض
علاقات مع الاحزاب السياسيه الديمقراطي
والجمهوري تاثير صناعه قرارات تحسين ظروف
حياه المسلمين والعرب هناك ثم انتكاسه
كبيره جدا ادت يعني الى 14 سنه تقريبا من
ظروف صعبه ثم سحب كل امتيازاتك وحقوقك
وتزويه مجحفه في المنطقه لكن تركيا ماذا
ترك
ب
[موسيقى]
ولكن قد يكون هناك ايضا ما افعله في في في
في اوطاننا يعني التسويه تقضي بخروجك لمده
عشر سنوات
والتسويه انك تتنازل عن كل حقوقك وتمضي
انك لا تعود الى امريكا على عشر سنوات
الان هل سيسمحوا لي او لا هذا امر يرجع
لهم
[موسيقى]
نشاط مجتمعي فاعل وتاثير سياسي متنامي ذلك
هو حال المسلمين الامريكيين الذين يشكلون
ثالث اكبر المجموعات الدينيه بعد
المسيحيين واليهود بتعداد قدر مطلع العام
الماضي بثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون شخص
تعود الى اشارات الحضور الاسلامي في
امريكا الى عدد من المستكشفين المغاربه
الذين عملوا لصالح الامبراطوريه الاسبانيه
في القرن السادس عشر ليتعزز ذلك الحضور
لاحقا عبر هجرات لاشخاص واسر من المسلمين
الى الولايات المتحده منتصف القرن التاسع
عشر
يتركز المسلمون اليوم في مدن نيويورك
وعرقيا يشكل العرب منهم نحو 30% ومثلهم من
الاسيويين اما السود فيشغلون نحو 25% في
حين يكمل البيض وذوي الاصول اللاتينيه
بقيه المكون الاسلامي في الولايات المتحده
ولطالما لفتى المسلمون في الولايات
المتحده لان ظهر اليهم بمشاركتهم الفاعله
واشتغالهم بالوظائف المرموقه ومن ثم كانوا
محل تقدير وهو تقدير ساهمت فيه شخصيات
مسلمه حظيت باجماع عموم المجتمع الامريكي
لكن احداث الحادي عشر من سبتمبر واتهام
مسلمين ملتمين الى تنظيم القاعده بتنفيذه
نجم عنه كبح صعود المكون الاسلامي بل وحد
من نشاطه بفعل التضييق الامني الذي استهدف
افراده ورموزه على مدى ما يزيد على عقد
كامل
ورغم الايجابيات التي حققها المكون
الاسلامي في امريكا فان ثمه معوقات حالت
دون تعاظم تاثيره ياتي في صدرتها تالفه من
مجموعات عرقيه وقطريه متفرقه نقلت معها
مشاكلها وتعقيداتها وهو ما اوجد حساسيات
تحول دون اندماجها وتعاونها دفاعا عن
مصالحها المشتركه في وطنها الجديد
[موسيقى]
ماذا فعلت في تركيا انا في تركيا طبعا
عرض علي ان اكون استاذا في الجامعه ولكن
انا يعني قلت انه عندي مشروع يعني وهذا
المشروع جزء منه ان يكون هناك مركز دراسات
وفعلا يعني بدات في في انشاء مركز دراسات
واعمل فيه الان ما القضايا التي تنشغل
ينشغل بالدكتور والمركز والله قضيه متعلقه
بالامه بالثورات الربيع العربي
[موسيقى]
بالتحولات الكبيره جدا التي تتم الان على
المستوى العالم الاسلامي وعلى المستوى
العالم ككل في صعود ووروز اقطاب اخرى غير
الولايات المتحده وحاول التحدث كثيرا عن
فهم هذا العالم وكذلك عن قضيه فلسطين
سابدا بها قضيه قضيه الربيع العربي
والثورات اللي حدثته هي الحدث المفصلي
تقريبا تحدثت عن تحديات كبيره تواجه الامه
تواجه شعوب المنطقه في الربيع العربي عن
تحديات اساسيه ما هي ابرز هذه التحديات
طبعا في انا كتبت في مقاله سبعه تحديات
ولكن قد يكون من ابرزها قضايا الاستبداد
والحريه والديمقراطيه والحريات قضايا
العلاقه الاسلام بالمجتمع قضايا الطائفيه
وفهمنا لكثير من القضايا اللي بسميها يعني
شروخ في داخل المجتمعات الاسلاميه
الطائفيه العلمانيه وفهمنا لها القوميه
وفهمنا لها الوطنيه وفهمنا لها العلاقه
الدين بالمجتمع كل هذه القضايا اللي هي
العلاقه المدنيه العسكريه قضايا ممكن ان
تسبب شروخا كبيره في داخل المجتمع راينا
ايضا قضايا متعلقه بالتنميه الاقتصاديه
بفهمنا للاتصال ولكن
الامر الاكبر في ذلك هو العلاقه بين
الاسلام والمجتمع من ناحيه والعلاقه بين
الدول المهيمنه والدول المهيمنه عليها من
ناحيه اخرى بمعنى انه لا بد ان نفهم انه
هذه الدول عندها استراتيجيات كبرى عظمى
ولكن احنا تغيب علينا هذه هذه الرؤى
وبالتالي كثيرا ما تاخذنا المشاكل الصغيره
ونضيع فيها المشاكل الكبرى خذ مثلا ما حدث
في مصر يعني كان هناك فرصه الحقيقه ولكن
هذه فرصه ضاعت بسبب بسبب عدم الفهم عدم
الفهم الوضع الدولي وعدم فهم الوضع
الاقليمي قبل الربيع العربي كان هناك
استعصاء
كبير جدا امام التحول الديمقراطي تبدو
الامور بعد الربيع العربي اكثر تعقيدا
بعدما تكشفت الاشياء وتكشفت ضعف الحركات
السياسيه ضعف المعارضه هزالتها عدم وجود
مشروع لها عدم فهمها كما ذكرت وكذلك قوه
الاستبداد وتغوله وانفه يعني
مساله التحول نحو الديمقراطيه انا في
تصوري ان قضيه الديمقراطيه لم تتاح في في
منطقتنا قبل انتزاع النفوذ الاجنبي
ان الديمقراطيه في فيتو لا يسمح لممارسه
الديمقراطيه في منطقتنا وبالتالي بدون
انتزاع النفوذ الغربي والنفوذ الاجنبي من
المنطقه لن يسمح للديمقراطيه انتم
صراع اساسي وجذري ووجودي طيب اسرائيل
موجوده وهي يعني راس هذا المشروع الذي
اصبح ليس اجنبي اصبح داخليا وانا في تصور
ذروه
انتزاع النفوذ الاجنبي والغربي هو تفريق
دوله اسرائيل وبالتالي في تصور ان هذه
نظرتي بالنسبه قضيه فلسطين من قضيه فلسطين
ليست قضيه دوله
انشاء دوله كما يدعي الجميع
واصبح المنغرسين ولا دوله ولا دولتين قضيه
فلسطين متعلقه بالوجود الصهيوني نفسه في
المنطقه وبالتالي هدفنا الاستراتيجي
الاكبر الان نحن ممكن نختلوا خطوات ولكن
الهدف الاستراتيجي الاكبر
الاستراتيجيه العظمى لنا هو تفكيك دوله
اسرائيل اي انتزاع الصهيونيه من فلسطين
هذا اكبر ضربه اجنبي
انا طبعا عندي
مساله طوباويه حاله جدا يعني المساله ليست
لعلاقه بالزمن لا علاقه بالعمل
اولا اسرائيل كايان وجودك اي كيان انساني
بشري له محدده له محددات له مقومات قوه
ففي حصريه الاستبعاد
في 12 محدد تتقوى بهم اسرائيل
وبالتالي هي اسرائيل يعني انا ممكن اذكر
بعضها موجود النقاط الاساسيه يعني مثلا
الحركه انه مشكلتنا اولا بدايه دعني اقول
ان مشكلتنا ليست مشكله دينيه بمعنى ان
مشكلتنا مع
اليهود ليست مشكله دينيه هذه مساله تكون
مفهومه ومنتهيه انا ما عنديش مشكله مع
دينه ان هو يبقى يهوديه اليهودي يبقى
ويعيش هنا وانا احمي ما عندي مشكله هذا
يعني الفقه
وتاريخا وحاضرا المشكله معي في الاعتداء
هو معتدي وبالتالي انا اواجهه لانه معتدين
هو عنده مشكله معك هو عنده مشكله اليوم
يريد دوله يهوديه هو هو يعتبر ان القضيه
دينيه انا لا اقع في هذا الفخ والشرك
واقول انه لا هذه رقم رقم اثنين انه كيف
انا اواجه هذا
العدو الصهيوني اواجهه من خلال المعرفه
الحقيقيه للنقاط فيه وقوته في 12 محدد
لحددناها هؤلاء نتعامل معهم حتى تجد انه
مثلا هاد زي بناء عليه 12 عمود فانت اذا
كسرت العميد يسقط البناء الان الفلسطيني
ممكن ان يؤثر في ثلاثه او اربعه من هذه
المحددات وبالتالي يجب ان نغير فهمنا لطبي
القضيه والصراع لا يمكن للفلسطيني وحده ان
يفكك الدوله ولا يمكن ان تفكك بدونه هذه
المعادله فانا لا استطيع ان اضع كل ماذا
يمكن الفلسطيني ان يفعل يعني يبقى على
ارضه يصمد يعني موضوع مثلا اول محددين
الحصريه والاستبعاد الحصريه بمعنى ان
الحركه الصهيونيه تريد ان
تجلب الشعوب او اليهوديه اللي هي من كل
انحاء الارض في فلسطين هي في عبر 125 سنه
جابت اقل من النصف سته مليون تقريبا سته
تقريبا كم عدد اليهود في العالم اليهود
في امريكا تقريبا وفي حوالي 6 مليون في
فلسطين
وبالتالي لم تستطع هذه الدوله طوال هذا
التاريخ الطويل والقوه والنفوذ والاقتصاد
المتنامي ان تجذب او تقنع حتى او تقنع
اليهود بالمجيء لانه ايضا في كلام عن
مغادره يهود وهذا الحادث الان وبالتالي
انت لم تتعامل هذه المساله تفكر بتكتيكات
كيف انه يصير في هجره عكسيه يعني حتى
يعني جماعه السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
يرعون امنا واقتصاد الصهاينه في اسرائيل
وهو الحقيقه بدا اوسلو قبل 20 سنه في 74
النقاط العشره نقاط العشر ثم تط بعد ذلك
الاعتراف 88 في جنيف
والجزائر ثم تطور بعد ذلك الى الى اوسلو
ثم بعد السلطه
الوطنيه يعني سلطه وظيفيه تخدم
بغض النظر عن كل ما يقال يستخدم الان
الوجود الاسرائيلي وتحميه من خلال التنسيق
الامني وهذه مساله مضي على الوقت انما انت
سالتني عن دوري فلسطين هو الحفاظ على
وجوده وبقائه
بقوه والمواجهات التي ياخذها الفلسطينيين
في القدس في داخل
في الداخل الفلسطيني طبعا في خزاب
المقاومه في الضفه حقيقه مواجهات
استثنائيه ولكن اشكاليه الفلسطينيين في
قيادتهم قيادات الفلسطينيه منظمه التحرير
السلطه فتح وما الى ذلك لا تسير في هذا
الاتجاه صحيح ولكن هي يعني في الاخر انا
اقول ان الشعب الفلسطيني سيستمر في نضاله
وكفاحه وجهاده ومقاومته وصموده ولكن حتى
لو اجتمعت كل هذه الفصائل انا مش ضدها
طبعا انا معنى لانه في الوحده قوه ايضا
ولكن لو اجتمعت فتح على حماس على الجهاد
على الجبهه على الديمقراطيه على كل
الفصائل الاخرى لن نؤثر الا في ثلاثه
اربعه وبالتالي يعني الشعب الفلسطيني شعب
الصغير هذا الدور الاول الصمود وهو مستمر
وباقي والاجيال الشابه تقدم تضحيات اكبر
مما قدمت سابقا المهم الثانيه هي الاشتباك
مع العدو الصهيوني والحركه الصهيونيه
والكيان الصهيوني
في كل شيء وكل مجال وكل جغرافيات سياسيا
اجتماعيا اقتصاديا ثقافيا اكاديميا حقيقيا
فنيا رياضيا في تجاريا على كل المستويات
تجابه وما تخليه يتنفس ولكن مش فقط من
الفلسطيني يعني انت جالس في امريكا مش
الفلسطيني انا اجيب امريكي
يشتبك معه في المانيا اجيب الماني في
بريطانيا اجيب بريطانيا هذا ايضا بعض
بوادره يعني ظهرت في كاس العالم نعم
الصحفي الصهيوني يصيح يشتكي انه نحن
مكروهون في العالم العربي لا احد يريد ان
يتعامل معنا طبعا هذا بعد حركه التطبيع
صار كانه في والله في قبول لنا في العالم
العربي كاس العالم في الدوحه كشف وجه رائع
حقيقته في التعامل مع اسرائيل ومعظمات
بالمناسبه المراسل ترى مراسل امني ولا مش
مراسل رياضي يعني هم يعرفون من بعثوا
والله فعلا يعني ناصعا ومثالا جميلا
ومثالا واضحا كيف ان اسرائيل مرفوض ويمكن
ان نحول هذه القضيه الى قضيه عالميه انا
كنت في احد في احد المباريات وكان جنبي من
الارجنتين في مباراه للارجنتين ويقول لي
فلسطين يعني
من نفسه يعني هو مجرد انه شاف كلمه
فكيف نحول هذا الاشتباك الى اشتباك عالمي
هذه تحتاج طبعا الى تخطيط وتحتاج الى
انشاء هذه الحركه ولا اتصور انه التعامل
مع هذه المساله عبر
الاوقات مع التحولات استراتيجيه ممكنه في
منطقتنا مع اضافه ان المجتمع الصهيوني
نفسه مجتمع مجتمع مفكك هو متحد علينا عندك
مشكله المستوطن مع غير المستوطن مشكله
العلماني مع المتدين عندك مشكله الكبير مع
الصغير مشكله
اليهود الشرقي واليهود الغربي اليهودي مع
العربي مشكلات لا لا حصر لها يمكن هذه
كلها ايضا تضعفها
بدون فلسطينيين ولا يمكن المواجهه
بالفلسطينيين فقط بالضبط ماذا عن غير
الفلسطينيه مع غير الفلسطيني يجب ان ياخذ
دوره انا مثلا انا اتكلم مثلا مع الاخوه
الاتراك انت مستهدف يا عزيزي انت لن نشرح
لك في المنطقه ان تكون انت متقدم صناعيا
او تكنولوجيا اكثر منهم او تكون انت مسلحا
او قويا اكثر منهم وبالتالي عندما تزداد
قوتك هم يحاربونك ويحشدون العالم ضدك في
الشرق المتوسط اليوم المشكله التركيه مثلا
على مستوى الاستراتيجي هي الطاقه لا يسمح
لها بان تنتج طاقه وبالتالي هم يجيشون
ويعملون تحالفات بين اليونان وقبرص
واسرائيل ومصر وكذا حتى يمنعوا تركيا من
الحصول على هذه الطاقه العراق عندما كان
يريد ان في اوقات ماضيه يريد ان يكون مثلا
متقدما علميا كانوا يقتلون علماء علماء في
البرنامج اللي كان يعني
ومغاربه وغيرهم في الغرب ويقت
لونهم اسمه رئيس انكلفاست اللي بيتكلم عن
سجل الاختيارات الاسلاميه ايضا
والايرانيين طبعا هم الان لانهم يعتبرونهم
من اكثر التهديدات لهم اكثر من 800 عمليه
ضرب النفوذ الغربي في المنطقه اذا هزمت
اذا تفككت اسرائيل فانت ضربته ثم كل
الامور الاخرى
ستاتي من نفسها وبالتالي انا غير معني
بصراحه اقول انا بدي حل حول دوله ولا
اثنين اللي فاقد دوله اسرائيل قرر يجي
بعدها وانا بهذا انقذ اليهوديه بالمناسبه
لان الصهيونيه غيرت معنى اليهوديه انا في
كفاحي ونضال هذا لن ارمي اليهود في البحر
انا اليهود اعتبر انا مسؤول عنهم انهم
يبقوا يهود متدينين ولا يكون عدوانيين
بمعنى ان اليهودي اذا لم تستوعبه اوروبا
لانها عنصريه وفاشيه يتفضل يجي عندي بس مش
يجي عندي صاحب سياده ولا صاحب وطن ولا
يجلس في فلسطين ياخذ المقدسات يجي يجلس
عندي من طنجه الى جاكرتا يروح اي مكان
يعجبه كمهاجر يجي عند كمواطن فما كان
اليهود كما كان اليهود في الدول الاسلاميه
عده اخر الدوله العثمانيه تتحدث عن خلق
حقائق جديده على الارض داخل اسرائيل يعني
فلسطين كيف يمكن عمل هذا الامر دكتور هم
يحاولوا احدى المحدداتهم انه يخلق حقائق
انهم يغيروا الوضع وبالتالي هم بداوا في
الثمانيه واربعين اولا
بقرار التقسيم اخذوا
من فلسطين ثم جاءت حرب 48 وصل الى 78 ثم
جاءت حرب السبعه وستين اخذوا خلف فلسطين
واخذوا الجولان واخذوا سيناء ثم راحوا
الليطاني هم هذه خلق حقائق جديده بداوا
ببعض المستوطنات كيف يمكننا ان نخلق
حقائقم على هذه والله هذه مساله نحتاج الى
خلق تكتكات يعني مثلا من ضمن الامور التي
يمكن ان نفعلها الشعب الفلسطيني ابدع
اشياء كثيره جدا في الانتفاضه الاولى لما
هم يمنعون مثلا من التعليم احنا كنا نخلق
مدارس نخلق جامعات نخلق اجواء يعني هذه
هذه الابداعات النضاليه والجهاديه التي
يمكن ان نخلقها على كل المستويات حتى في
موضوع المواجهه يعني مثلا اسرائيليين الان
هم عندهم مشاكل كبيره جدا في اقامه
مؤتمرات في اوروبا
وبالتالي هم يحاولوا يخترقون في بعض
المجتمعات الان سواء كانوا في الامارات او
في تركيا او في غيرها احنا نخلق ايضا يعني
تكتيكات اخرى نمنع عنهم ذلك وكذلك نمنع
عنهم في مناطق كثيره ماذا عن السلام دكتور
لماذا
تغيب مثل هذه الفكره
المطروحه انه يمكن
الوصول لها عن سلام بين في اسرائيل
وفلسطنين
يعني هذه الفكره كانت تقال طبعا طيله
النضال واسس التي دخل فيها ياسر عرفات الى
الى الى اوسلو ان هناك سيكون سلاما وكذلك
سمعناها قبل ذلك من الرئيس السادات في مصر
وكذلك مع وادي عربه وكذا ما هو السلام
السلام الذي يقصدونه هنا هو الهيمنه
الاسرائيلي الكامله انك تقبل بالاسرائيلي
وتقبل في وجوده في فلسطين
بفكرته هو تقبل به كدوله يهوديه وبالتالي
هي المهيمنه وبما يفرضه عليك هذا هو
السلام الذي عندهم ليس سلاما مبني على عدل
او سلام مبني على اعطاء الحقوق وارجاعها
وبالتالي اي سلامه نتحدث عنهم يعني ليس
هناك حقيقه
وهم مقتنعين بذلك
عقود 30 سنه خلينا نقول قرابه 30 سنه كان
في قضايا سموها قضايا الحل النهائي الحدود
والقدس واللاجئين
اتبعت بالكامل لا يوجد حدود قدس بطريق
يعني ابتلعها بالكامل اللاجئين مساله هذه
غير مطروحه اطلاقا في الواضح هذا يؤكد
حديث الاشخاص الذين لا يؤمنون بالسلام هو
اصلا كلمه السلام خادعه
بس كانت شعار برا الشعار يطلع مستمر على
الناس يعني هو اذا كان هناك سلاما حقيقيا
او او يعني انت شوف كل التجارب لها علاقه
بالتسويات اصلا هي ما فيش السلام هو يعني
غياب الحرب بالنسبه لهم هو سلام لهم وليس
سلاما لنا لانه احنا عايشين في معاناه الى
الان زادت عن 75 سنه لم تقف يوما واحدا
فعندما نتحدث عن سلام نتحدث عن تسويه ثم
يريد التسويه لا يكون فيها ارجاع الحقوق
انما هي القبول بالامر الواقع قبول بما هم
يطرحونه من امور سياسيه هم قالوا من زمن
ان فلسطين هي الاردن يعني مزعجين دوله
يروحوا الفلسطينيين في الاردن وهي هذه هذا
ما نستطيع يعني يبقى شويه فلسطينيين لخدمه
الدوله الصهي ومع كل هذا لن يعطوك حفظ
السياده يعني هم لما عملوا كم ديفيد مع
مصير اخذوا السياده في سيناء لم يعملوا اي
امور اخرى هم يريدون ان يحافظوا على
وجودهم وعلى هيمنتهم هذه مساله يجب ان
نعرفها جيدا يعني اذا ما كنا عارفينها
ندركها الصهيوني الاسرائيلي هو دائما يخاف
على نفسه ولا يمكن ان يقتنع حتى بالسلام
لانه ممكن في وقت مؤقت انت تتقوى لن يسمح
انك تتقوى لن يسمح الى اليوم مثلا كثير من
دول الخليج مثلا ما عندها حاله حرب حقيقيه
صحيح ما اعترفتش فيه بعضهم ما في حرب
حقيقيه ولكن هل تعطى السعوديه مثلا سلاحا
يمكن ان يضرب اسرائيل يستحيل اذا انت
ستبقى دائما مهيمن عليك نقص السياده مهما
اعطوك من اشياء ستبقى ناقص سياده لانه
اسرائيل يجب ان تبقى ليس فقط قويه ولكن
قويه على كل تفوقها التكنولوجيا والعلمي
والعسكري على كل جيرانها مجتمعين اذا احنا
اردنا ان نعيش في مثل هذه الاجواء اذا
احنا في مشكله فينا
يعني هل ترى من الضروري مواجهه عربيه ان
تواجه الدول العربيه اسرائيل من اجل
فلسطين ام من اجل نفسها لا نعتقد ما في
فرق يعني هو الفلسطيني والعربي المفروض
انهم يعني نفس القضيه اذا حين المساله هذه
على على العرب مهددون تحدثنا العرب مهددون
كيف العربي يعني مثلا اعطيك مثال للسودان
بدات الفكره الصهيونيه في تقسيم السودان
عام 57
سبعه وخمسين السودان اخذت استقلالها في
واحد واحد 56 بدات تفكير في تقسيم السودان
في اسرائيل في الدوائر الاستثماريه عام 57
وبدات مجموعه عمل في داخل الموساد تعمل
على ذلك عندما استقلت جنوب السودان في
2010 في اول زياره لرئيس جنوب السودان الى
الى الى الكيان الصهيوني وقف وقال اذا كان
هناك لاحد فضل على خلق جنوب السودان فهو
هذا الرجل هذا الرجل كان رئيس لستيشن رئيس
محطه الموساد في جنوب السودان لعشرات من
السنين
اذا كانت هناك دوله كرديه محاوله لاقامه
الدوله كرديه اللي هي ممكن تخلق زعزعه انا
مش طبعا حقوق الاكراد الاكراد يعني مهمشون
ولهم حقوق كثيره ولكن انشاء دوله كرديه
هذه مساله استراتيجيه في الفكر الصهيوني
وهي اشياء دوله حاجز لانهم ممكن ان يقيموا
معها علاقات وتصبح هناك يعني يعني وتوجد
دول اثنيه عرقيه مذهبيه كما يحدث ايضا في
العراق وفي سوريا ان يصير مبرر وجود دوله
يهوديه لانه في دوله كرديه دوله مثلا
شيعيه دوله مثلا مسيحيه الى اخره واكثر من
ذلك انه هذه الدوله نحن متقدمون عنهم
جميعا وعندنا علاقه استراتيجيه مع اقوى
دول العالم وبالتالي ممكن ان اتحكم يعني
مثلا هناك خطه صدرت عام 82 كان شارون كان
مدير مكتب شارون هو اللي وضعها وشارون كان
يتحدث عنها في مؤتمر في يوليو 83 في
النيتو في مؤتمر النيتو السنوي وهو تقسيم
المنطق الى ثلاثه واربعين دوله
هذه خطه موجوده بخرائط وبالتالي انت مهدد
يا عزيزي السعوديه مهدده بالتقسيم
والسودان مهدد بالتقسيم وليبيا مهدده
بالتقسيم وسوريا مهدده بالتقسيم هذه الشيء
انا لا هم يقولونها مش انا اقول يعني هم
يعترفون بذلك ان كلما تقسمت المساله في
هذه الخطه التي ذكرها شارون ولا وقتها
ترجمتها بالمناسبه لما قلت لك في الفتره
ما بين 82 384 هذه احدى الخطب التي
ترجمناها وما كان لها اسم سميتها الخارطه
الجديده للشرق الاوسط واتضح انها مبنيه
على خطه ممكن كل انسان يشوفها اليوم اسمها
هذا الرجل كان مدير مكتب شارون بتتحدث عن
ثلاثه
ومنها طبعا كان موضوع جنوب السودان
وغيرها يعني فالمنطقه كلها مهدده هل انت
تريد ان نحن يعني بعد ما كنا امه موحده
بدل ما نتحد نتجزا
السبب في مثلا ضرب احدى الاسباب في ضرب
الوحده بين مصر وسوريا كانت طبعا اسرائيل
تعمل ليلا نهار لو ذهبنا الى موضوع الربيع
العربي انا كنت في واشنطن وقتها طول الوقت
كنت اكتب مقالات عديده يعني تحت اسم
المستعار ولكن كنت اشوف امام عيني الدوره
الاسرائيلي ودول بعض الاخوه
الدول الاخرى في ضرب انظمه الدول العربيه
اسرائيل كانت معنيه لانه كان في كل يد
تحمل علم وطني وقومي كانت في اليد الاخرى
امام فلسطين كما راينا في كاس العالم اذا
هذه مساله بالنسبه لها هامه جدا
واستراتيجيه هي عدم السماح ليس فقط
بالوحده ولا بالديمقراطيه ولا بالان الى
نسير يعني بعيدا عن ما يجب ان يحدث وما
نتمنى ان يحدث واقعيا الامور تصير لصالح
اسرائيل هو قاعد بالظاهر نعم ولكن ايضا
هناك في ديناميات هناك في يعني يعني تدافع
كبير جدا في داخل المنطقه المنطقه لم
تنتهي ولم تعطي يعني صوتها الاخير انا
اعتقد ان احنا مقذلون ايضا على موجات
جديده لانه ماذا يحدث في المنطقه الان لا
يمكن ان يستمر لا يمكن ان تستمر هذه
الحاله من الضعف وحاله من الفقر وحاله
المشروع والفوضى لا صعب صعب جدا يعني
وبالتالي سيكون هناك ايضا موجات جديده
وهذه الموجات يجب ان يتبعها ايضا تخطيط
مسبق يعني اذا لاي مشروع اذا اجتمعت فيه
اجماع الرؤيه واجماع الاراده واجماع العمل
والامكانات سينجح انت ابن الحركه
الاسلاميه دكتور سامي بشكل عام لاحظت يعني
توجهاتك النقديه لها قديما يعني وبالذات
جماعه الاخوان المسلمين اليوم بعد التجربه
الربيع العربي وبعد التجربه التي ممكنه
للاسلاميين فيها ان ان يحكموا ليس بظروف
طبعا يسيره ومثاليه ولكن على الاقل اتيحت
فرصه في اكثر من من بلد عربي سواء في تونس
او في مصر او حتى في المغرب بطريقه او
باخرى باليمن الى اخره ما تقييمك لاداء
هذه الحركات الاسلام يه
وواقعها والمراجعات الواجبه لما هي عليه
والله احنا اقمت العامل الماضي
سته سبعه ندوات
بحوالي مئه ساعه
تم فيها
تقييم 16 حركه
معظمه في العالم العربي بالاضافه الى
ايران ومقبلون على ثلاث ندوات اخرى سيكون
في ايضا خمسين ساعه ستقوم في 11 تجربه
اخرى وبالتالي هذا موضوع يشغلنا جدا في
المركز بشكل عام في موضوع الربيع العربي
كان هناك حقيقه عدم وعي وعدم ادراك لكثير
من الحركات
الاسلاميه ان الثورات هذا علم يعني لنجاح
الثورات لا بد لماذا الثورات قليله في في
تاريخ العالم لانه حتى تنجح لابد ان يجتمع
معها كثير من العوامل كلها تجتمع هناك
عوامل ضروريه وعوامل محليه وعوامل هيكليه
الذي حدث الحقيقه لم تكن ثورات حقيقيه لان
لم تجتمع هذه العوامل خصوصا العوامل
الهيكليه في هناك سبع عوامل هيكليه لابد
ان تجتمع
يعني اولا الفلسفه الثوريه الفكره الثوريه
التي وراها النظريه الثوريه ثم القياده
الثوريه ثم
الاجهزه الثوريه ثم الطليعه الثوريه
والجيش الثوري والاستراتيجيه والامكانات
كل هذه تضعها ما كان هناك قياده ثوريه
اللي كانت تحت الدجاجات
ممكن عمليه اصلاح او عمليه استخدام
للجماهير في عمليه تغيير ليس لها علاقه
بالقوى المعارضه كما كما كانت في بعض
البلدان وبالتالي ليس هناك فهما حقيقيا
لموضوع الثوره يعني الثورات الحقيقيه التي
تمت في التاريخ الانساني الثوره الكوبيه
لتقلب
الطبقات يعني التي تسيطر على السلطه
والثروه بقلبه البناء والمؤسس لبناء جديد
الان من الذي يريد ان يحدث التغيير
الاخوان المسلمون في تصوري ليست قوه ثوريه
وغير قادره على الصنع تغيير ثوري فلا يمكن
ان تتحدث بلغه ثوره وانت فاقد لكل مقومات
هذه فانت تتكلم عن عمليه اصلاحيه وهم
قادرون على ذلك يعني وبالتالي احنا خدعنا
الجماهير الجماهير خدعت بنا هي تظن ان
هناك ثورات وبالتالي هناك في تغييرات
حقيقيه وجذريه في المجتمع
وحتى في تونس لم تكن حتى في اي مكان اخر
لم تقل وبالتالي لا تتحدث بلغه انت لا
تستطيع ان
يعني فكره
توصيفها ثوريا هي اصلا من الاساس خاطئه
احتجاجات انتفاضات شيء ضاغط على اجراء
تغييرات جزئيه في طبيعه النظام نفسه وهذا
الذي حدث هو استغلت والجماهير للاسف
الشديد ايضا يعني تريد من يقودها وبالتالي
تعبت الجماهير تعبت وهذا كان مقصودا ايضا
والقوه المضاده للثوره كانت تحلم ذلك جيدا
وهي حاطه فيتو هناك في اعتراض لن تكون
هناك تجربه ديمقراطيه ناجحه في المنطقه
هذا يهدد وبالتالي نفهم التجربه التونسيه
لماذا احبطت امريكا التي تحدثت في كل مكان
عن الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان ودوله
القانون والحريات ايش لم تساعد التجربه
التونسيه باي شيء بل ارادتها ان تجهض وانت
تهزم وان تفشل وهذا وبالتالي خلينا نضع
يعني نذهب من من اذهاننا من عقولنا ان
نتصور ان هذا الغرب سيساعدنا في هذه
المساله لا طب احنا من ناحيه نتهم بالتدخل
واذا لم يتدخل نتهمه يعني نطالبه بالتدخل
لماذا نريد ان تتداخل امريكا لتحمل
الديمقراطيه الذي اذا فشلهم التواصل
بكل اطيافهم السياسيه وفي مصر المصريين
وفي كل مكان
الامر الاول مرات نمارس موقف ازدواج مع
الغرب يعني نتهمه بانه يجهض الديموقراطيه
وحينما لا يتدخل نريد منه ان يتدخل اولا
اريد من المفكر العربي ومن الانسان العربي
ان يفهم الهدف الامريكي
هم فعلا يريدون تغيير النهضه من حزب ديني
الى حزب سياسيا هم فعلا يريدون ان يخوضوا
التجربه الديمقراطيه وابنه عارفين ذلك
ولكن هناك فيتو غير مسموح لك انت تقول
انهم اخطاوا ما الذي كان يجب مثال انا
ممكن اعطي
ك من عندك بصندوق النقد الدولي
ين قليله
كان يمكن حلت كثير
قامت بها وليست ثوريه ولكن هي لم تعطى
والصندوق الدولي هو احد الادوات التي
تستخدمها امريكا في الضغوط على الشعوب في
حين اعطت اوكرانيا عشرات مش عشرات
الملايين من خلال اسبوع او اسبوعين ايش
تحتاجوني اعطيه اعطيه اعطيه اعطيه هذا
صندوق الدولي صندوق النقد الدولي الذي هو
بنك الدوري عنده اسيد عنده تريليون دولار
ما يقدر يعطي تونس 4-5000 او مصر ايام
مرسي طبعا يقدر ولكن هو ممنوع علينا الان
ماذا كان يمكن ان يكون هو شوف هو لازم
يختاروا يعني يعني خيار حقيقي اذا كان
خيارا ثوريا
عليهم انما لا يمكن ان تقول ثوره وما
تشتغل على عوامل ما الثورات هاديه في
الاخر يعني يعني حصيله جهد والجهد هذا
واحد اثنين ثلاثه لازم تفهم ال 15 تدعو
انه كان على الاقل يتم تبني الخيار
اجتثاثي
اذا كانوا اذا كانوا يريد ثوره لها مساره
طيب اذا تريد اعمل الاصلاح عمليه اصلاحيه
شوف بقى
هل تعتقد ان الخيار الاصلاح خيار صائب ام
خاطئ هو حسب المنطقه يعني هو في الاخر انت
لا تستطيع ايضا ان تكون عندك ثورات في 15
دوله يعني يجب الناس تفكر في مكان مكانين
لانه ما عندناش هذه الامكانات انك يكون
عندك ثوره في تونس وثوره في ليبيا وثوره
في سوريا وثوره في مصر ثوره
وفي الاردن ممكن يعني يجب تشوف ايش
المنطقه الاستراتيجيه التي تصلح لها
الثوره وتشتغل عليها ثم بعد ذلك سيكون
هناك تحولات
اخرى يعني ليس المشكله الحقيقيه ليس عندنا
عقلا استراتيجيا يفكر
على بالنسبه للامه ما هي خطواتنا التي كل
واحد بفكر على كيف كل واحد بفكر في مصلحته
انه المجموعه كلها يعني جالسه في مكان
واحد وتفكر بهذه القضايا مجتمعه ما هو كل
الفعل فعليا كل ناس مشغولين بقضاياهم وهذا
هو الواقع وبالتالي يسهل الاستفراد بهم
وهزيمتهم
الان يعني هذه المجموعه يعني الثوره
السوريه على سبيل المثال الثوره السوريه
لعب فيها مع انها يعني يعني كانت يعني
يعني عليها اجماعا عربيا لعب فيها من كل
الانظمه دكتور العابر الحدود يعني
المشاريع القوميه كانت عابر الحدود وصلنا
اخر شيء عندنا بعد في سوريا وعندنا بعد في
بغداد وتصارعوا على امور تافهه وتاريخ سيء
حقيقه فالمشروع القومي الوحدوي سقط جو
الاسلاميين وكانوا هم ايضا التنظيم الدولي
والعالمي ومجموعات الاخوان الموجوده في كل
بلد عربي ومتفاهمة وعقيده واحده وايضا
اثبتوا في نهايه المطاف انه لا يوجد شيء
جام ع ومشترك بينهم بالتالي يعني كان
نظريه نظريه كل يعني معني بشؤونه واصلاح
امره هي هي الاكثر صحه والاكثر جحانا ربما
يعني
[موسيقى]
نفرق بين امرين الامر الاول الفكره
والامر الثاني تطبيقها الناس يعني ممكن
يكون عندك فكره صحيحه ولكن لا نعرف
يطبقوها فافشلوها ممكن عندك فكره خاطئه
ولكن عندك ناس ممتازين جدا ما استطاعوا
لان الفكره خاطئه من اصلها وبالتالي لابد
ان نفرق بين الامرين لا نخلط المسائل في
بعضها الان التيار القومي التيار الاسلامي
الطيار الوطني الطيارات المختلفه يجب ان
نرى كيف تشخص المساله وما هي طرقها في حل
التشخيص انا اتصور انه عندنا مشاكل جذريه
وتحدثت عن ما هي الاستراتيجيه العظمى كل
مجموعه كل دوله يجب ان يكون عندها هدف
استراتيجي كبير هدف عظيم هدف يمكن ان يكون
هو المسيطر او المهم او الاولويه وهذا قد
ياخذ بالمناسبه 50 سنه يعني امريكا اشتغلت
على ثلاثه استراتيجيات او اربع
استراتيجيات في تاريخها 250 سنه كل واحد
اخذ ممكن تاخذ 100 سنه
مش مساله تتغير بتغير واحد او اثنين
وتبدا في وضع استراتيجيات الوصول الى هذه
الاستراتيجيه العظمى الكبرى
انا اقول انه استراتيجيتنا الكبرى الان هي
احنا في مرحله احنا اذا اخذنا دوله
المدينه
الى سقوط الخلافه الاسلاميه في العثمانيه
هذه 1300 سنه هذه مرحله سماها الفيلسوف
المفكر السوداني ابو القاسم حاج حمد
العالميه الاسلاميه الاولى نحن الان في
خضم بناء عالميه اسلاميه ثانيه هذه ممكن
تاخذ 50 سنه معنا ولكن نفهم ما هو الهدف
وما هي الاستراتيجيه توصلنا الى هذا الهدف
ما نفكر انا بحل ايش احل الكويت مشات
الكويت ومشاكل السعوديه ومشاكل قطر ومشاكل
الاردن ومشاكل سوريا كل واحد يفكر بنفسه
لا هذا لن تصل الى شيء
الحلقه سعيد جدا بوجودك في المقابله في
حلقتين استعرضت جانبا من من سيرتك ومسيرتك
وكذلك القضايا الاشكاليه التي تهم اليوم
العالم العربي شاكر ومقدر لوجودك شكرا
جزيلا شكرا مشاهدينا الكرام الدكتور سامي
العريان الاستاذ الشؤون العامه ورئيس مدير
مركز الدراسات الاسلام والشؤون العالميه
ضيفي في حلقتين الماضيتين شكرا لكم وانتم
على طيب المتابعه القاكم ان شاء الله في
الاسبوع المقبل في امان الله
[موسيقى]